government and people of ethiopia are
outraged over the western media's
coverage of what is happening in this
country
for more than a year rebels belonging to
the tigram people's liberation army the
tpla have been embroiled in a bitter war
trying to overthrow the democratically
elected government
instead of remaining neutral
mainstream western media has chosen to
take sides a majority of ethiopians in
ethiopia as well as abroad strongly feel
that cnn has covered the conflict over
the past year in a manner that is highly
biased and detached from context the new
york times insists on repeatedly falsely
claiming that it was the government of
prime minister abi ahmed cnn hasn't
fared much better
a news anchor with the largest ethiopian
television channel has monitored and
reported on the false reports the
channel continues to spew out
for example
when tplf marches to addis ababa you
know
they they are at the six kilometer
away from addis
cnn reported that
addis ababa is under siege by tplf
this completely fake neos and they used
fake picture
another
the ethiopian airlines is transferring
to region
but in practical the european airlines
is not doing that things factually
but cnn transmitted in order to attack
the ethiopian economy al jazeera
published a video clip on facebook with
the heading thousands of tigrayans
arrested in ethiopia it shows a video of
vigilantes and states that they are
looking for tigrams but what it doesn't
mention is that these vigilantes were
heeding a call from the government to go
out and protect their own neighborhoods
against tigrans who were coming in
looting and killing people on november
26th the french state-owned
international media outlet france24
reported that some tplf fighters had
reached deborah sinha some 30 kilometers
from addis ababa it was simply untrue as
picked up by a fact-finding organization
in the capital city wants to sell uh
fall city
but it's big it's it's becoming that the
real facts are becoming boring
experts agree the mainstream press is
talking with one voice suggesting a
coordinated effort behind the scenes
and and not only the media the
ngos the right groups like amnesty or
human rights watch they also collect
these reports and the sample assemble a
report
and then feed the congressmen the
european union and then they
use it to
impose sanctions the ethiopian
government says it's clear that western
media is willfully and deliberately
choosing to misinform its audiences
it's unfortunate because during war time
more than ever
credible reporting is urgent
policy rt addis ababa ethiopia